[Music]
welcome back to off the record we talk
about whatever we want we got stevie
weeby back hey
finally after like a few years yeah it's
been two years since you were back
having fun man i love talking about this
stuff i haven't seen you yeah in two
years i look up to you guys i always
have too oh you guys helped me because
at the beginning like when i was just
starting my podcast i'd always i just
asked you guys for pointers like how
long do you guys film what camera do you
use and so you stole all of our ideas
and you took it away i have a little mix
you guys have canons i have a lumix but
i like your guys's drive you guys
work hard i've been seeing you doing
multiple podcasts now i'm doing a lot
now
a lot but i wasn't gonna miss this i was
20 minutes early you were you're very
early has being more
um in other people's like uh podcast
made you more on time and i tend to zone
out a lot now like
because you know when you're on so many
podcasts you just
you sometimes you get like desensitized
sometimes you're just talking all day
yeah so i'm just like well you don't
know what story you told where
and then i got in trouble with jeremiah
because i i repeat like sometimes when i
do stuff i just blink out and i forget
and sometimes i'll repeat like
the same story like i'll say on king the
sting and then
they'll drop their stuff and then ours
drops like the next day and
then jeremiah will be like hey how can
you talk to a rerun
it's a rerun yeah sucks and then uploads
like stevie's fifi bag
and so last time i had i i did it again
right yeah the same type of thing but i
caught it like after i got home i was
gonna take a power nap and i go oh no i
did it again
so i had to contact the producer i had
to contact jeremiah i had a text theo it
was a whole thing so what do you do then
you chop out like half of the podcast no
no i have no control it's there that's
their pocket i'm a guest on like me
being a guest here what was that you're
just letting them know like i just i
might i let them know my concerns i go
hey you know i forgot
and how many of those are you going to
do here here no no well i did talk about
you know i talk about jerking off all
the time though i think yeah people know
about that
people know all my jerk off stories
there's nothing to hide at this point
yeah yeah yeah it's all out there what
do you do with the butt okay you were
talking it's in the closet okay steven
it's in the closet it's a big plastic
butt what do you do you have a butt is
it plastic but i got a black black you
got to plug it in or how does it work no
it's like a it's like a it's like a
flash flashlight is black is black a
brand name or is it a color it's a black
butt okay it's a right you got it yeah
yeah totally good and you could use the
butthole and the vagina oh really yeah
so the yeah how do you clean it when you
when you bust inside it's washing liquid
i mean you flip it inside out or what do
you do
[Laughter]
yeah how do you or do you like just
stick a hose to it you take it to the
point hey man i had a flashlight there's
no shame in the game okay but at least
for a flashlight at the other end
there's a hole
and you when you bust it i know how to
clean a flashlight yeah
i'm telling the viewers at home you
could turn the hot water on and you
could flush it through but i've taken
showers with it too the black butt
because it's so efficient
because you can shampoo your head and
then you it's like kill two birds with
one stone
shampoo and then you'll put some of the
shampoo sets yeah wow so that's another
little yeah
he's a sexual maverick i like that you
like that too and you're open-minded
yeah yeah yes but what do you say about
the blackboard yeah so the vagina part
the only thing i stopped using it
because the first night i used it i i
had oil too i had this you know the oil
that turns hot yeah so i i
i laid the towel down and um i got on my
back and then i had my uh
phone but then so she rode you she was
riding you yeah cool yeah so that's not
reverse it was regular cowgirl cowgirl
you didn't reverse it yet no i didn't
reverse it yet no yeah but i did in the
future
but anyway so i got yeah i got the video
ready and then
i like i like lost balance and so it got
lopsided well i like the lost balance
part of that all the oil it just all the
oil yeah dude just like a real woman
yeah yeah
what's your go-to video you want to know
for real yeah okay
wait one two i'll go one through five
whatever whatever whatever number one
tuk tuk patrol what's that what's that
you guys don't know you had heard of
that before like that's the in the
philippines in thailand you don't know
what
tukktuk is like the [ __ ] motorized
vehicle so was it like bang bus but with
a tuck tuck no that's the name of the
channel
patrol so what's the concept of tuk-tuk
patrol it's like
thailand women filipino yeah like
southeast asia yes they say exactly
number two grandma granny cream pie
grandma for real oh yeah really it's the
best what is it what about gravy
i got your tuck tuck patrol right here
no no it's called tucked up patrol i
thought they were on there
there's no tucker's in here
looks like regular asian porn but show
us granny green pie what about what
about granny's tourney one wait so your
favorite is you like southeast asian
girls is that your favorite i like it
all right well that's her
pacino's adventures no no let's go back
to the brandy stuff
one at a time one at a time grammys
no
number two grannies what about granny's
turning once yeah he didn't know what is
it it's just because he's like they're
skinny i don't know it just happens but
is it because it's just wrong but it's
right but how but how did you fall upon
this like as you were scrolling i think
i just came across it on x videos and
i'm like i'll watch it and she was i
mean it has to be 60 plus yeah she asked
me at least 70 plus on the show
on the streets do like if you saw granny
do you get turned no it's more like the
fantasy element of the video
it's more like a you know it's a
personal fantasy because another thing
is because they're
not all of them out there most of them
are infertile at that age so in my mind
i'm like oh you can nut inside yeah
you know like
my mind goes into like a nursing home
like oh i could get through what if i
worked in a nurse you know like you know
it's like fantasy yeah it's like role
playing they [ __ ] like crazy at nursing
homes and they got hella stds dude yeah
it's right here
when you're that age we won't be there
up in there too why are they called this
pacino's adventure yeah pacino's look it
up look it up i got it latino women
colombian women and latino women yeah
yeah
pacino's adventures he's talking about
like a little a little chance yeah right
here yeah this is very niche you like
you like uh tan girls he likes this like
this chick right here
what just happened is uh admiral
immediately went to a girl just grabbing
dicks and sucking the [ __ ] out of her no
that wasn't it this is adventures she
looks very hungry adventures that's all
we got
what's the fourth one four wait so you
go to these paid sites and then you like
the niche ones no but this is okay
i also do this uh
yes
it's uh just uh solo masturbation like
pov like dildo videos that's normal okay
you're ashamed of that but not grandma
i'm coming cheetah's adventure is pretty
tame just making out jesus
this guy's glasses is my favorite why
does he look like he's in 2002.
is that what you like no i just like
dude i mean the women are looking at how
beautiful the women are yeah they're hot
why is the iso so high
why is the exposure really really up
there they need to white balance that
[ __ ] dude
okay so dildo pov that's not bad number
five okay what's the fifth one this this
is more of a specific search but like
um i got you right here thailand i do
thai cream pie
cream pie i i'm we're seeing southeast
asian green pie we're seeing a
connection here over and over and it's
not the cream pie
chicks tan chicks and cream pies i like
it all though i like it all dude i
search specifically for cream pies
though because i want to finish at the
same time oh there's a thing called
family therapy where it's like more
role-playing yeah yeah so look up family
therapy yeah family therapy on it do you
like the step brothers like certain
yeah i like the stepbrother and the
step-sister scenario i like that yeah
and then i do you're the devil this is
just taking me to counseling centers no
family therapy on x videos oh my god oh
next video yeah yeah so these are these
are specific channels x video is your
go-to platform versus like pornhub oh no
no no no oh
no i'm missing a major one okay yeah
yeah one a-a-m-w-f
a-m-w-s what is that asian meal
are you covering your eyes
wait hold on i'm not why are you ashamed
am w and wf cream uncensored [ __ ]
uncensored because there's a difference
between the two why because this is
japanese yeah a lot of them there yeah
what's with the pixels bro why do they
do that it's illegal penetration is
illegal in japan it's [ __ ] weird dude
like filming it mm-hmm yeah that was a
little just penetration
dude it's [ __ ] weird so like you go
to 7-eleven and just buy straight-up
porn comics or whatever but it's all
pixelated today's video is brought to
you by feels cbd is not about what you
feel it's about what you do not feel
such as
pain and stress i hate all that [ __ ]
yeah usually i take it before like bed
if i need to sleep but this time i
actually took it before a workout
what yeah i had like this weird like it
band issue and it was inflamed
so i talked to my physical therapist and
he was like oh that's just kind of like
a pain issue like you still have to do
you're rubbing it out and all the
therapy
but he was like so you can still train
um but the pain part you just need to
kind of manage it and i was like i don't
want to like not train and i know that
it's not something that's going to
continuously hurt me so i took cbd and i
was able to feel more relaxed and the
pain kind of went away for a little bit
that's good so that actually really
helped out i was able to continue to
train so i didn't have to
like take two weeks off and then ruin my
training so i really liked that part
that was cool it's a pretty good way of
having some type of support when you
wanna ease the pain a little bit in your
body i personally like it myself and
it's really simple and easy to do you
just use a few drops of fields and you
go
and you enjoy the feel running through
your body chilling you out and if this
is your first time you intimidated you
don't know how much to use they have a
hotline just for you that you can call
and be like what are you wearing oh i
mean uh
what how many fields should i be using
yeah and also join the fields monthly
membership and you can save money on
every single order super easy to use and
you can cancel at any time
so if you need something to help with
your pain or stress and anxiety you can
become a member today by going to
feels.com off the record to get fifty
percent off your first order plus free
shipping that's f e a l s dot com slash
off the record to get fifty percent off
plus free shipping thank you very much
thank you
i do love the japanese stuff too i can't
lie i love it they've been coming out
with some newer stuff because before
what's the new hot [ __ ] the jab j-a-v
that channel because their bodies are
getting better
the jab channel yeah
because before their bodies weren't so
hot but now everyone's like working out
and getting hotter and and then i think
like
the they're actually getting like fitter
people to do it oh yeah dude they're
great all of those are great i just
started doing some deep dives there's a
there's all indian desire here we go
indian desire what's that about i gotta
see this one too yeah
the industry
a restaurant
i think you have a type
it is brown girls i like white i like
browns
he says amf
amwf that's why that's why yeah but but
most of all we saw the other four were
all brown yeah
granny cream pies most of those are most
of them are white grannies how about a w
a w yeah you like aw
i also i clicked an ad on accident i
found chicks from overwatch getting
[ __ ]
up
yeah i'm not into that it looks like
very cartoony steve i remember we had a
porn chat one time and you said that you
really liked the pov stuff and you
couldn't move away from that yeah so now
you moved obviously because look at all
these other but there was a time only
like the pov stuff right yeah i i got
off that though i never got on it
it's good stuff
have you done the vr one wait i revealed
all my bit of my soul
i'm always revealing my soul let's go
around the circle yeah i i bear my no
you just weren't here when we did it bar
likes real estate i like real estate and
girls peeing they're the best oh the
property sex one yeah oh the property
sex one's pretty funny something about
chicks and business suits i don't know
this guy loves business
business and pleasure
chicks and businesses i like rusty
trombones
and um
a harem sex what's that harem sex is
like don't judge me
multiple girls nicki's not around watch
it tonight dude it's just chick's
[ __ ] no no you have to watch you have
to give it a shot you have to watch
what's this
no you got to hear the dialogue and you
need the black butt yeah what's special
about pacino's adventures
what about cause they go to columbia
they go to ecuador they go to like the
south i mean you know what i mean yeah
you like equator sex because all of the
people you like regional sex bro you're
like it's all equators what do you mean
original well it's very specific like
genetically attracted to a certain
longitude i like it all
i know i'm covering a huge spectrum here
you are india
thailand granny philippines colombia
yeah it's all on the equator
that's all i love no i don't
discriminate
of course that's really good he's got
like a white grandmother magnetic
compass of true oh i like interracial
cream pie too yeah interracial is good
interracial is very good a lot of
international classic interracial is fan
favorite you know it's a hometown
favorite okay so you're a cream pie fan
such as mine right such as me do you
like multiple cream pie what's that what
is that no no not really and i can't i
can't watch the video where there's more
than one i don't i don't like that
either
thing i don't like the orchid thing is
that a hot tank
i don't like
gang
i don't like that no no i don't want to
watch that no gaming
i don't want to work but
i like multiple cream pie it's [ __ ]
different what's the difference
what is that what's the difference
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is different because it's one
girl and then a guy goes up and busts
and another guy goes up and busts and
another guy goes up and busts it's like
a whole factory sounds like a no again
[Music]
okay so here for example for example
this is multiple [ __ ] no that's a
gang bang oh no that's what it is
that's what it is
he's so perturbed
is when there's two there's guys doing
it at once a multiple [ __ ] is one
person taking on one individual at a
time yeah but it's the same concept
they're just in a single file line yeah
it's waiting for their order yeah
they're the same thing i like structure
yeah
it's kind of
dude there's actually a japanese
challenge where it's like 200 husbands
or some [ __ ]
and then you could nut to that she goes
in and there's a guy this guy's just
waiting and she [ __ ] one after another
and then it's like i'm just like dude
this girl is 200. it's like a kyokushin
[ __ ] black belt challenge
where you were you [ __ ] fight man
where you [ __ ] fight every single guy
and see if you could make them that's
too much dna you know so just imagine
all that well dude for a quarter
oh that's a lot yeah that's a lot that's
a lot that tells me that she's very
talented and she can make all these
people come really fast they better give
her a fat check for that yeah how much
she deserves
100 000 for that day
100 000
for that i think it's a little light do
you like glory hole
all the stuff you like i don't want have
you seen them
there's a penis in the hole and then you
it's there's no intimacy something he
wants in the musty but there's this is
kind of intimate
okay
[Laughter]
hey what else hey look my okay you want
you want intimacy why are you showing me
this
you brought it up i do this on my own
time though it's weird singing
let's [ __ ] go bro put his hand on his
leg
but i don't mind two women and one man i
never mind that
i don't think anybody
yeah you want intimacy stevie
milking table
milking table it starts with the therapy
session i love steve going awesomeness
there's a there it's a therapy session
and then
they're with the massage therapist and
then the guy be like oh i can't get a
hard on anymore and she goes i know
right the right thing to do and then she
massages him and he flips over and
there's a hole and his dick goes through
and then she sucks it from the bottom oh
dude this is two chicks oh no that's not
my cup that's one of my favorite ones
maybe with holes bro oh man how come you
don't like this tea oh that's the one
that's the one massage therapist sucking
a dick what's wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with it it's just
you know what that's not bad but you
like
[Applause]
you like
carefully right you like
you know everyone's taking [ __ ] together
hey guys we're all [ __ ] together it's
like it's weird
that would be really weird we'd say that
again it would be really weird if we all
had our dicks
you know but we're not we're good we're
chilling you guys didn't sleep is that
possible today
we should do that for a future challenge
we're giving this [ __ ] away from the
patreon yeah so this is what i propose
if you guys are open-minded okay go
ahead and turn your ideas oh no that's
not my idea no but just tell me okay
let's say what you just said the show's
going far then i thought
we were talking about it it'd be really
weird if all of our dicks were out and
we were looking at porn all together you
guys didn't do circle jerk championships
with your friends yeah yeah i showed my
friend yeah
i shot my friend i played he was a white
guy too yeah i showed him how to to beat
off but is this circle jerk like my hand
and his dick his hand no
what the [ __ ] bart whoa
did you want me to google that you
[ __ ] yeah you piece of [ __ ] what is
one standing or you don't place
yeah so i thought whoever nuts first was
the winner we all could not first yeah
who can't melt with other people other
dudes around you
but we're jacking each other off though
no we're that's the real circle let's
not do
i was more like we're all jerking off
individually
but we're in the same room like right
now like
doing this and i'm looking at you know
when they're talking about like oh
hollywood they're just a bunch of circle
jerkers it's cause they're jacking each
other off no no we're not gonna do that
it's the same idea we're all naked why
are we naked now my idea
i thought we were wearing jeans with our
dicks and we're all just we're all it's
a contest yeah
but we're not touching each other i
thought a circle jerk is a half circle
not a full circle and you're watching
pour together and you're jacking off no
i think circles we're supposed to jack
each other off i just love that there's
an absolute wrong way to do this
but a definite right way that's not
disgusting at all
in a circle because that's where the
phrase is you're not checking him off
supposed to that's where they go oh
holly hollywood they just circle jerk
each other right all you guys think is
black and white bro okay
that's right a circle jerk is you form a
circle here's the thing and you're
jerking everyone's naked just jerking
off in a circle but it's not challenging
so here's i've looked it up what a
circle jerk is you have to jerk it to
something that maybe you wouldn't
normally jerk it to
[Laughter]
so whoever comes bro i've jerked onto
this plenty of times dog turn that off
dude let's try let's do an experiment
let's just try right now but we don't
we'll just do it under our panel
dude hey pull up brandon cream
historical
dude don't turn the camera
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you